your performance as Princess Diana is
the main reason why I love this season
of the crown so much you were just so
fantastic in this what parts of Diana's
mannerisms were very important for you
to get right
um
all of them I think all the ones that I
that I observed and thought were
crucial and I think when you are
observing the physicality of a person
the the question is always why why is
that developed in a certain way and what
does it mean and where does it come from
so I guess sort of like all of them and
equally the voice was
really important for me to try and get
as close to it as I could and kind of
yeah
The Voice everything about the voice is
just so spectacular uh there was so much
excitement surrounding this season in
particular of a show that's already so
popular you've had Mariah Carey having a
screening night she had her own tiara on
sitting on the couch with a beautiful
dress how much of a fan were you of the
crown before signing on
but I saw that Mariah Carey thing in it
I was so excited because I I'm obsessed
with her and I thought oh my gosh once I
want to step closer one step closer
um I was a huge fan I was a I was a huge
fan because a very dear friend of mine
one of my best friends Vanessa plays
Princess Margaret in the first two
seasons so I watched it I watched it
because she was in and I watched it
because it was this huge deal when it
came out the first season was like this
never seen before the sort of how
incredible it was and how expensive it
was and how amazing the performances
were so
um yeah I was I was a naturally huge fan
of the show
so your friend must have freaked then
well that's the thing we we talk about
it all the time and actually she's been
such an incredible resource for me just
even sort of in the lead up to to the
show coming out and she's she's she's
such an amazing friend and she's so so
grounding but she definitely went
through it so I love it and you know a a
big part of when we think of Princess
Diana and who she was we just love so
much all these amazing fashion moments
that she had especially in the 90s
obviously from the Revenge dress the
Harvard sweater is there a particular
outfit that stands out to you that you
feel really represents who Diana was in
her essence
this is a combination I think the fact
that they they almost
sort of can be put into different
categories and I think that that's
because she was a person who had to sort
of wear so many different hats and or so
many different masks in a way to present
certain areas of her life and I think as
an actor playing this role the thing
that was always the most interesting to
me is what does she wear when she needs
to be most herself and what is that you
know because we all have a version of
that in our real life what does it look
like when you get home and you know you
take your bar off and you put your
sweats on and you feel like a human
again that what is the version for these
people when they get to sort of become
more vulnerable and more undone and raw
and so that was the thing that I was
really interested in finding with the
costume designers
uh and I'm gonna get the wrap in a
second but you know we all have this
idea from Princess analysts especially
in the 90s and everything that she went
through is there anything that stands
out to you in terms of what surprised
you the most in the research that you
did when it comes to what she was really
going through during that time yeah I
think I think her journey with the media
and How Deeply it affected her and her
um psychological State and how I think
in in the earlier parts of her life the
media were Kinder and I think they were
maybe perhaps more onside and she had a
kind of more reciprocal relationship
with them and and I think where we get
to in the story that Peter's telling in
season five is just how
potentially damaging it was and a lot of
that really really surprised me
I can only imagine uh well
congratulations on this series I hope
you get to have your mom with Mariah
Carey one day
I really hope I hope